can I just start by congratulating
Kristen I to say thank you for being so
brave has been coming out just a couple
of days ago so I'd like to thank you for
giving hope and inspiration to young
children who are still in the closet I
just like to say thank
you
hearing stuff like that makes it worth
it you know but I I have to say you know
I've been out since I was um 14 years
old um the first person I ever told was
my mother you know it's it's just I've
been lucky to have the support of my
friends and family my entire life but it
was just so weird to mention something
so casually in an interview and because
it's not a big deal to me I I I expect
it not to be a big deal to the rest of
the world you know and it shouldn't be a
big deal to the rest of the world for
anybody I agree but what I've said is if
if one person out there can can feel a
little bit better or um identify with
one other person you know I'll take the
flock I don't care I have my support
network and I don't care what other
people think about me as long as your
friends and family are there so but
there you
go